[Musique]
alors vous vous souvenez au mois de juin
on a organisé les premiers weekends
démocrates partout en France au bord des
étanss sur la plage pour certains dans
les forêts dans des salles communales ou
dans des bistr ont été organisé ce
formidable moment de convivialité pour
parler politique alors ça a été un
succès formidable on a été très nombreux
et donc on remet ça on remet ça là bien
ô le 24 25 et 26 novembre alors ça sera
pas dehors parce que c'est l'hiver mais
ça sera dans les bistr dans les cafés
dans des salles communales avec le même
objectif discuter confronter nos idées
faire émerger des idées des projets de
territoire voilà ce qu'on aime faire au
Mouvement Démocrate faire de la
politique en convivialité et en
sympathie donc rendez-vous 24 25 et 26
novembre partout en France